Growth sprout.
Biting my time.
Duck tape.
Two peas in a pond.
Escape goat.
You know that mortifying moment
when you use a common phrase
in front of everyone,
only to find out you've been
saying it wrong for years?
Well, the good news is you can
stop that shame spiral in its tracks
because, according to the nice folks
at the Oxford English Dictionary,
we've all done it.
Mishearing popular idioms,
metaphors and sayings
is much more common
than you'd think and actually
if enough people
make the same mistake
it can come to take root
in our collective consciousness.
Sometimes even replacing
the original phrasing entirely.
For example,
if someone were wildly mistaken,
would you say they had
another thing coming
or another think coming?
Believe it or not,
according to Oxford's
language monitoring databases
the original phrase was
another think coming,
which to lots of you
probably sounds all kinds of wrong.
If someone strips down
to their birthday suit,
would you say they were
butt naked or buck naked?
While buck naked
is the earlier form,
nobody would bat an eyelid
or, to misuse a common phrase,
an eyelash, if you were
to say 'butt naked'.
These are the sort of changes
that keep lexicographers busy
updating their dictionaries
so that they reflect how language
is really being used by people,
rather than instruct on how
language should be used.
So tell that to the next pedant
who tries to correct you.
In fact, many common turns of
phrase have had fascinating journeys
evolving into the popular sayings
we all know and love today.
To curry favour, meaning to
ingratiate yourself with someone,
has nothing to do with buttering them
up by buying them a vindaloo.
Its original form was actually
to curry Favel,
which will make
absolutely no sense to you
unless you've brushed up
on your medieval French literature.
Favel, or Fauvel,
was the name of a horse
in an early 14th Century poem
who was renowned
for his cunning and duplicity.
To curry Favel meant to groom
him with a special comb,
still called a curry comb today.
Favel was commonly misheard as favour
and the rest, as they say,
is history.
Basically the term 'to curry favour'
has lived such a rich life
it would probably have
a much better Tinder bio than you.
Social media in general
has proved the perfect place
to mercilessly take the mickey out of
some of the more amusing mishearings.
Linguist Geoffrey Pullum
coined the term eggcorn
to describe these
idiosyncratic substitutions
after a woman famously said "eggcorn"
when she meant "acorn".
This name stuck,
and has since spawned many a listicle
of people's favourite examples,
from the fairly logical damp squid
for damp squib - squib being now a
little-known word for a firework -
to the cringeworthy
all intensive purposes for
all intents and purposes.
While eggcorns can be great fun,
nothing brings people together
like a misheard line or lyric.
Since the 1950s
these have been known as mondegreens
after American writer Sylvia Wright
described mishearing
a line from a poem
"Laid him on the green"
as "Lady Mondegreen".
Even Taylor Swift isn't immune
to a mondegreen,
with listeners widely hearing,
"Long list of ex-lovers"
in Blank Space as,
"Lonely Starbucks lovers".
Another lol-worthy
linguistic muddle up
is the malaphor -
a blend of malapropism
the mistaken use of a word
in place of a similar-sounding one,
and metaphor.
A malaphor is a mixed up idiom.
For example,
"It's not rocket surgery"
or "It'll be a walk in the cake."
So next time you're at a party
and you say
"We'll burn that bridge
when we get to it,"
"The cows came home to roost,"
or "Every cloud has a silver spoon
in its mouth," remember,
you're not making a mistake
you're contributing to the evolution
of the English language.
You're basically Shakespeare,
and one of these days your mistake
might just end up
in the English dictionary.
What's your most embarrassing
malaphor or eggcorn?
Thanks for watching.
Don’t forget to subscribe! :)